it's gonna cost a fortune the important  thing is  everybody's alive okay insurance will  cover it  tell me you've got insurance you've got  i'm sure that's true great fully comp  was  expensive  what what what are we gonna do we've got  no car no signal  what are we gonna do i don't know do you  no no i don't then how about  how about a little equality because i'm  no more equipped to deal with any of  this than any of you  sorry someone will find us i'm gonna  realize that we haven't checked back  into the lodge  no they won't you drove through the gate  without registering  do you remember no one knows that we're  here okay so we go back out onto one of  the main roads and get some help  i mean there were cars that were passing  by we can't go walking through the bush  that's crazy  aren't you supposed to wait by where the  accident happened that's what they teach  you wait and then someone comes  on a closed back road yeah exactly how  is anyone gonna find us here  [Music]